hmm
okay hi everyone
uh
we have another live stream here
um
and we are looking at flight data
um
and
let's see
uh you also have a rough page you said
yes
all right so let's understand what this
basically is
so this is we've had functionality in
waltham alpha for a long time
for
can i see something more impressive okay
so this page
it's called done
okay there we go so all right
now what happens if i want a 3d flight
map
not yet
okay
because we would have to hold it totally
on its own i think we should wait under
the geographic 3d
yeah
and probably the geo
trajectory trajectory function
right
okay but but if i want to get for
example the sequence of geo points here
that exists right yes
so for example if i've got if i wanted
to get um
[Music]
the uh the height of that let's look at
that particular flight
um we should pick an airline that we
don't think is going to go out of
business anytime soon
um for our examples
but it's it's flights it's concrete
flights
so it will always be there because i
know the flight has already existed
okay all right so let's let's take this
as an example
and how do i get the sequence of geo
points out well how do i get the heights
out
you can ask for the altitude or if you
want
the full thing you can get the
the position which will have the
altitude well no no what i want is a
time series of the altitude
right
how do i get that
so that would be flight data of the
flight
altitude and then comma all which we'll
get all of the
as a time series yes
obviously we're not auto completing
correctly yet
that was nice and zippy
okay so if i now say dateless plot
cool
that's really cool
i mean we've obviously had got that data
involved from alpha but but this is
really nice to be able to get this
programmatically
um
right so let's find out um
and presumably we can also do this as a
i see this could be
that could be a dated query yes
yeah
oh
no i don't think no not no
but it could be
i mean it will be more timed than dated
something
maybe
yeah right now it's mostly set up to
work to fly data right don't use the
entity on its own yet
yeah
there's some data you can get out of the
entity but not not the
oh where should i store this
does it get its own thing
sorry what are you saying
right now use flight data as the
accessor not uh yet uh sub values to the
entities okay all right fine but that's
that's a becoming attraction yeah
okay do we think we want a timed as well
as a dated
to deal with this a case like this
i'm not sure do you mean timed instead
of dated yeah because because it's going
to be from 3 p.m to 4 p.m
and it's a little bit weird to say dated
you know that's fine if it's 16 44 or
something
as opposed to 16 44 p.m you know
you know central time or something but
on the other side introducing a simple
time just for this purpose seems a
little bit overkill then we should think
about other users oh no no obviously
obviously obviously obviously
obviously i'm suggesting that as a
um
you know it's just like we have all the
stateless plots and i mean that's a
discussion probably an lcc discussion
about time versus date yeah and
and because i think there's an argument
that you know
dateless plot there should also be a
timeless plot that has some slight
slightly different um
um
you know defaults but is otherwise very
similar right
and that i would suggest as a um
uh is is there anybody project managing
here
probably not
okay so so can i
take some can somebody here take that to
lccc
okay all right let's keep going here
um
and uh
all right so let me understand a few
more things so so if i want to know
of that flight what type of plane was on
that flight
what was that flight sorry what type of
plane was that flight
what is that
it's uh aircraft aircraft yeah
shouldn't that be called aircraft type
that's weird why would it not be
available
unfortunately i think our data there is
fairly spotty
okay but but
um
okay my question by the way i think it
should be called aircraft type okay and
by the way
you know there are situations like with
with private planes general aviation
where there's a tail number right
right
do we have to where is the tail number
how do we get the tail number
did you understand my question we don't
have this
ever
yeah i thought we could no no no i think
i've seen them somewhere
okay i'm sure for general aviation we
have tail numbers in fact i've seen them
come up in our data
yes
we have to i have seen them too
and those
okay why did that fail
hmm
okay what's this
uh bizarre
entity id that's a flight id presumably
a little bit like
um
okay
yeah those are the standard names within
flight data
are those sequential by flight takeoff
time in a day or something roughly
i believe so
okay
do we like that kind of i mean i i don't
think it's horrifying that standard name
comments about it
it's around as good the standard names
are for people or other things
okay
and if we extend to international we'll
just have a different designator for
that
right
yeah
so there'll be some some kind of i mean
we're thinking about this
i mean if if we think we i mean you know
it might be worth adding a us designator
at the beginning of this
u.s 2021 blah blah blah
did you get what i'm saying
yeah and the designator would be the
starting point
what place well yeah okay it could also
be the data source in some sense but
yeah you're right that there might be
there might be two
there might be versions of the same
flight
with different data sources
definitely
i see so be the originating country okay
so maybe we i don't know how we deal
with that
okay maybe there's some
simple thing we can do here to indicate
that
i mean if these are just designated
names we could just add a letter at the
beginning of this to indicate this is
our current
you know f something or other yep
something
or even i mean this comes from the faa
does it not yeah
so what about a designator faa blah blah
blah blah blah is that their designation
that we're using here
no i think this is
uh where does it come from and what what
is that designator
okay why don't you go find that out okay
if this is close to that designator i
would recommend using something like
this
that makes sense yeah
um
okay
so now let's take a look
um
flight path
yes this will be the geo position
with altitude information and so forth
okay so those are
those are the raw
values of this then
right
now does that flight path have that the
geo positions have times in them
presumably because geo positions can
have times in them right
um
okay so let's say normal
a percent nine
oh gosh why does how does this how do i
get the individual geo positions out of
this you will have to take the first
part
okay this isn't what i thought it was
right that isn't right it doesn't have
the timestamps yeah
right that's
well wait a minute let's be clear geo
position can have time stamps can it not
no
that's not true
um
oh no it has height but it i thought it
had a time stamp as well
pretty sure that was part of what was
going to be geotrajectory yes i think so
okay all right okay i'm wrong then okay
so geotrajectory
okay fine then this is what it is and
the third element there is the correct
uh that looks very unconvincing that
looks very unconvincing that is above
the operational ceiling of of a typical
plane if that's in meters and that
quantity is in meters right right
uh but that is what's what the the
sources give us no no no no what are you
talking about what are you talking about
i i think kind of it's a unit issue
it's wrong it's just plain wrong
yeah that's in feet
but this is in meters
so either we have to now it's a round
number in feet
which is good but for the geo position
we have to give it meters otherwise
we'll just get completely the wrong
answer yeah
i thought i made some experiments and it
was working correct
right but but but what do you do with
the fact that it isn't a round number of
meters
did you understand what i'm asking yeah
so i mean here for example i could say
geodesk this is going to be a cute thing
watch this
can i just say geodisc of all of those i
guess i probably can
and i can say
um
geographics
probably not work
because geodes does not want this three
arc list
oh geovisible region
they will also not work
i think they would they
okay
that's not good why doesn't that work i
think it works only for a single one
so that's again that should be fixed how
do i how do i break this into single
ones
i do not know of a way to do this
okay so this is a problem which we need
to talk about
i can't discuss with society
what the heck is this
again uh
i think geo
vista
no it should work right this work
but that's wrong as well
because first to percent nine
how far did this plane fly
oh not very far
so because of your crazy geo positions
which are obviously wrong right
the plane can see as soon as it takes
off
um
that's amusing
um
okay but but anyway that workflow is
messy right and should be cleaned up
yeah
um
okay let's go back here so now one of
the big questions is
how do i find
okay so given a flight
i understand this now future flights
if i say of that flight
i mean i don't understand there must be
lots of future flights here well that
was only a master this year but but this
is not with respect to a flight
what does that mean
that's future flights of that
i don't know why those entities didn't
format
did you understand my question
this is the prototype yeah
okay fine
i mean you're asking is this prototype
build yeah
i think so let's check
yeah
who knows it's a bug
okay
now
what you were also showing i think in
your agenda here
is what it takes to find something
goofed out there
um
search for flights by okay that's nice
so for example if i want to find
how can that be the only one
by default it's going to look for the
current day so there's going to be one
flight
for that that current day matching
what happens if i want all flights for
southwest airlines
uh that's not supported at the moment
well probably should be
so
so what happens i don't understand where
it's said for the current day
look it should not be called flights if
it's for the current day it should say
daily flights or something
how do i get the flights for the last
week
uh with with the third argument uh for
the time period that you're interested
in
flight number 1644 right
okay so how do i get last week
the last week
um so you'd have a date
a date range so
of
no no no is it a list of days or what is
it
uh
it's a beginning and end date
okay so it's like weather data
yes
so it's now minus two weeks
to now
that doesn't look convincing
don't believe it
in fact we already know that that's not
correct
because we already have
a
on august 9th
1644. okay so let's say i go back
10 weeks
no that's nonsense yeah
no look into what's what's breaking
there
should be coming up with
more than that
well it's just wrong i mean it's just
not
what it's doing is it's just going to
that
first date
right that's that's the date
i don't even know what that is ten weeks
ago it's you know sometime in june or
that doesn't seem even right
who knows it's broken
okay
so
that was finding a flight number now
wait a minute
oh that's cool
that's really cool
that's cool you can do that that's
really nice
okay so let's let's try
let's try something fairly minor
um
let's try not not these well okay that's
okay let's do this
let's just see what happens if i
generate all of them
okay so i'm going wrong with the entity
designation but now if i were to plot
flight data
actually this is going to be really
interesting flight data flight path
right
type data
of that now presumably i can take the
whole list and i can say flight path yes
yeah we'll give a list of fight clause
yes right
well an association
why is an association of the for each
the
you want to preserve from which it comes
i think i see i see i see i see i see
so now if i say
what do i want to say i want to say
joelesplot of this don't i
that might
now we have an example like that in
in the documentation uh
what the heck is that i'm not sure if
jesus wants the association okay well if
it doesn't it should take yeah
okay
oh my gosh what's this
help
okay all right so let's let's take
values because i really want to see this
percent 25.
um
so now what this should give us right is
is a so presumably the joined
this will show us the bundle of jd6 so
to speak between those two airports
right
and it will give us some
what's the implication of actually that
bundle of gd6 it's going to give us
something about the effective curvature
of the
okay that is super ugly
that has many problems like why didn't
earth did it do this stupid thing here
and why are these so thick
but this is
just the default useful behavior well
okay but that's bad so in this case it's
that did a bad thing
okay
i'm very very confused by why
the geolist plot
produced these weird okay so my next
question my very fundamental question is
if these things are going to jfk
okay here's what you did wrong in my
view
you chop to those things based on time
of day those are the red eyes
i claim
and you lost the other part of the
red-eye flight
i'm saying
yeah i get what you're saying um
let's see
just double checking
um why on earth it did this why did it
do this i've never
that's absolutely not something it
should do
yeah that might be the case that it got
shocked yeah all right well we can fix
that
okay glad we tried
across the country version to know that
um
right i think flight path should be the
complete flight path independent of the
day right
yeah
um that's really interesting though
there's so much deviation
yeah
wow it's different the airlines also
that's true
why did it do this that's so goofy what
it did there
i think that has to do with the fact
that those are all geoposition
rappers anyway show them this example
um
okay all right let's take a look at a
few other things here and then we should
wrap soon this is wonderful go guys this
is really wonderful i think that i've
been waiting for this for so long but
this is this is exceeding expectations
in terms of the kinds of cool things you
can do
um
okay i do have to try the one obvious
mathematical thing what am i gonna
try what am i going to try
you know what i'm going to try
no
that should surely be another list
okay
right
i am not convinced you might have uh
a thing make a loop for sightings i i
know that but then missing not available
isn't the right answer it's you didn't
find any
i'm not sure what's the difference
because missing not available but if you
return a list we would claim there
weren't any but we don't know this
well but wait a minute
what we're returning is the flights we
have in the flight database correct
right
but this is not the viewpoint we take on
data
the viewpoint we take data is
you know kind of we answer a question
about the real world
not if we have it
but isn't this returning a list by
default
yes
uh and there will be an association but
yes
but in this case we we don't have any
there we go
cannot guarantee there wasn't any okay
fine
okay
so
let me just check this if i say
something like so these are non-stop
flights right
right
no we don't have
that's fine
so that's actually really kind of
interesting because just even counting
the number of flights is interesting
right
so like let's say we say
um
i'm curious about this
and you can have also say on the right
side uh
a white card to get all flights
[Music]
okay why can't i have all then
i should be able to have all arrow all
right yeah you can replace yeah that's
what i mean yep there you go
wow
cooler source now how do i find out
where those flights went to
um you could uh go to destination
destination
yeah station airport
where is that
that's
first d
right there
that says departure airport oh departure
arrival airport sorry
okay so flight data
percent
why is that slow
i think it's the entity rendering
for the airports i think so too what the
heck is that doing
okay let's drill into that one because i
don't know what that one those must be
private
okay
by the way
what on earth are some of these
that's a really weird one
let's find out what that flight was
i'm predicting private flight but that
must have been a jet okay let's go find
out what that flight was
okay so now what do we do here so i take
that entity and i say flight data yeah
i can just say data set
that is truly odd
don't you agree
it's a very obscure
interesting
i don't know i can't comment
people have private planes here in
champaign yeah right there
you can tuck it
right yes
right
why is there that why is there that
thing there what is that oh that's a
ah tail number
oh yeah
yeah
that's not an airline it's uh no i
understand that but why doesn't this
show
when it says airline
yes you should say missing private
missing general aviation okay
in this case if we know it
right
status that's a really lame status
i mean that i assume that there's a
do we have entities for flight status
no no
what should we have for flight status
likely entity would be the
there would be basically just three yeah
no there could be many more
idling right if it's landed if it's
boarded
but we don't know this
i mean from the ones that we know
we only know it's
it's in the future it's happening or
it's in the past i think that's all the
only three we know you don't know if
it's rerouted to some other airport
i don't know do we know this
i'm looking up i think you're i think
you're right michael that there's only
three okay
so there's no delayed option
but sideshow this is
right now
thank you is it in the air or not
oh wait and if not then kind of slight
refinement there are there are seven
possibilities
there's landed in flight delayed
filed in scheduled
and then arrival status unknown
and schedule expired basically
so we could have a small ep table for
that canceled could you cancel also
right
uh well that's
not i mean i think that would be
uh schedule expired
it would be odd to have an entity for
something that never happened
but you have it at the airport i mean
what you see on the board there right as
you see it's cancelled or it's delayed
the question is what is a flight
it's it's a very quantum kind of
question yes yeah it's a specific
instance
it's a scheduled event if it's not
happening then it's not well not if it's
general aviation it's not
if i had to fly okay so general aviation
i can imagine a situation where somebody
files a flight plan
but they never do it
they never execute it
yeah
but that's okay i mean so
what we need to say is flight data is
you know because it is in fact it's
registered it does not include
general aviation okay here's a question
does it include
you know if you're flying a random
little cessna
okay it clearly doesn't include that
right correct
yes
otherwise you would see this in the
champagne okay i think this is you know
whatever it is um you know part i forget
the numbers 5 30 or something i don't
remember this but it's some type of some
type of flight that this is
okay with some kind of flight plan and
some kind of tracking information so we
should specify what it is that we're
actually giving
does that make sense
i'll find that information and make sure
it's documented
um but because there's a flight school
at champaign airport and you can learn
to fly you know in champaign
what are you talking about
bjorn
it's beyond it's an airport it has
planes at it
what point are you making well they have
a separate hangar already there's stores
a little place where the people
yes i realized that i know that what's
your point
the point was okay that's not all
flights are uh show up here
right no that's right but it is a
particular type of flight that shows up
which is designated by some faa
yes exactly
okay and and that will inform
what i suspect is the case which is that
flight plans that are not executed show
up here
okay
that's really bizarre i see this is
that's based on its flight plan right
right
exactly
right so it left early
that was fast
[Music]
i just looked it up it's a it's a
little hawker plane
um
anyway
okay
so what else should we look at here
um
okay
time to landing time since take off
yeah there's a lot yeah
maybe we should have i mean what do we
have oh we have departure do i all right
by the way
you know i have to say i i think that
these should be broken up into more
subcategories on the documentation page
because i'm having a really hard time
finding things here okay
um
flight path is weird because a lot of
these are
you know after the fact
okay
mean speed if i ask for it for a plane
that already happened
okay so if i say here oh mean speed
makes sense
but if i say here
okay so this flight already happened
and now i say altitude what's it going
to say it's going to say 0
no because it's not
in the air
okay don't say not applicable say
something like make it more explicit
you know
uh what should we say
not flying no that seems rather silly
what should we say
it's on the ground
not acting no no no it's a flight it's
not the airplane
right
so it's it's more that uh flights
conclude current or not current yeah
well
it might be it might be that it's in the
future what about
flight completed
it might be in the future michael
yeah
um
flight not active flight not current
flight not in progress oh that's good no
not in progress
flight not in progress something like
that okay
um
by the way ethan suggests that we
compute the
traveling salesman tour but look at this
it's a jd6 bundle
and not gd6
that's a lovely plot it's very
interesting i'm really surprised at how
big that deviation is
other interesting things one can do i
played a little bit around like take 100
random flights and show
in the beginning and ending the starting
and ending phase height versus time
gives you also nearly universal power
laws yeah that example is further down
in the documentation
got that in there
it's near the bottom down underneath
that's an interesting plot that's an
interesting thing i would do a date
histogram of that
okay actually i'm i'm now curious just
for my own probably for a bigger airport
more interesting i'm gonna do lax
so this is the daily one right yeah
so what is a day
um
midnight to midnight
okay so this will be
in
in local time zone
yeah
what happens when there's a time change
oh not um
not local time it's uh it's it's all in
utc
that's stupid
then for this
because the the look no no i mean you're
saying that because that that hits the
middle of a day right
yeah
so that's crazy
what the heck is this
so you understand that this why is that
17 why is why such weird times why is
that date histogram not not showing up
with better labeling could somebody make
a screen capture complain to brett and
so on about that
okay but the question here is and by the
way if i do this again i assume
you might see some change
well no no not too fast
i mean i'm i'm going to let's say
how many does that give me five things
per bin or something was that five bins
i can't remember that's
every five
things
or with the five
probably
i think so too
also who knows what it's going to look
like but but okay so time zone is a
problem right what are we going to do
with time zones
what are we going to do for the daily i
mean i think we want in local time but
what do we do with the time
switches
oh my gosh there it is but very very
very faint
yeah well that wasn't so bright on my
part okay whatever
um
okay so that's that's really interesting
actually
why are two why are there two
it's like tides why are there two things
per day
unless this is just so messed up in
terms of times
and okay
are we converting to local time
we should we should give everything in
local time
yeah this utc isn't isn't right
i should have noticed that before
right
what do flights that they're usually
flights are usually given in that in
their in that departure time zone right
yeah
6 p.m to such and such
right yeah
okay so we can we can make that
conversion
um
okay
so what were you saying michael you were
saying
oh that's cool i think these examples by
the way are overly complex and should be
okay flights overhead
yeah that's a wfr that we've
uh
put out
in the last few months
right
this thing that michael was commenting
on
there's a bit more dance yeah you're
almost there there yes
okay
that's that's planes climbing yeah
right
i'm actually surprised there aren't more
you know oh i see that's too low if you
go higher you're going to see
different flight levels breaking up
right it's like climb to i don't know
flight level 3-0 or something it'll be
as opposed to 3-1 or 3-2 or whatever
else
so you'll see it it should should break
into i mean assuming that i mean what
you had before was things which i mean
you know had
had um
uh
um round numbers
and feet at least
yeah i'm a little concerned about the
conversion to meet us and the fact that
we're going to break up all those round
numbers
and i think we need to look at this
again
makes sense yeah
um
frozen is commenting that
the on a live stream that it should be
in utc yeah the local time function does
correctly wrap it so the thing you get
is a time marker that it knows is in
such and such a time zone so if you
convert to another time zone it will it
will do the right thing
so for example what should be the case
okay so
the departure time and the arrival time
should both be stated as
um
date objects
in their
appropriate time zone
for where they for where they are
right right so to figure out if you want
to figure out the duration of the flight
it's one minus the other and it will
correctly do the time zone conversion
right yeah
yeah we'll just have to
include that time zone info and
the data that we do yes we do we need to
be careful about that knowing you know
we'll have to do the you know the cash
look up of the arrival and departure
cities but we don't want to do that
dynamically
do you understand what i'm saying yeah
yeah
um okay well this looks lovely
very interesting
and um
okay we make the changes i just love
this plot i want to see more judicial
bundles i mean this is just like like um
uh um
i'm just
i'm almost um if that didn't have the
glitch i would probably even tweet this
because i'm so
keen on on the concept of um
anyway okay
um
so you want for the bundle you want them
both so that's the same day at the
start airport the same day at the
end airport
no no no no
no steven just want to make sure that if
a flight goes overnight that we don't
lose something right we don't chop the
data
we get the whole thing right so this is
the initiated
during
the last day and i think there's going
to be a little bit more trickiness about
the last day yeah
right but i think the last day should
always refer to the
starting airport
i think it should be the starting output
that's what time flights are quoted in
terms of uh you know the the 6 pm from
wherever yeah
i i'm reminded of a from 30 years ago
okay stupid story i have to tell i think
it was american airlines i can't
remember but but some some airline
um they had this telephone information
system where you could call
and find when a flight was going to
arrive because that was before the web
and all that kind of thing
and so i called to find out when a fight
is going to arrive and the flight had
been delayed from the current day
across the midnight to something
slightly after midnight
and the system went bonkers
and
you know
as as part of my responsibility as a
you know software technology person i
reported that bug
i forget what it even took to report it
but it was kind of an interesting
process to actually report that bug
because i don't know if they fixed it
but they seemed to be happy that it was
reported
um
just kind of one of those funny things
um
got some voucher for 500 miles forth
i should have done that yeah but i think
by the time by the time the person you
were reporting it to was so far away
from anybody capable of issuing vouchers
that um
uh
um
let's see
um
yeah frozen is commenting about utc and
getting local time yeah we already have
all that stuff come on use fine
geolocation of a flight that's a good
idea
why not
we might as well hook that up
it might be tricky because
we assume normally that the objects are
static
but find your location if you feed it
an entity for a flight
probably could do the right thing
it's a corner case
okay
so i'm still not quite sure what should
it do
well i think i think what it would do is
it would look at the flight
if it's in the air then fine where does
it where does it have flight location
where does it have current location
um you can get the
the position precision
yeah
the third one below yeah and that should
not be capitalized
but
um
okay
ethan is complaining that that he wants
more advanced
content in his live streams
that there are different ones about
different things
but also commenting on on
uh
more computer vision okay we're gonna
have some more about video video content
i believe
um
and the compiler you will be hearing
more than you could possibly
ever want about the compiler quite soon
um
okay
ethan is pointing out that there's a
nice video from
you sung
from 10 years ago about flight pods
yup
what is that what is that
i think he made this for sick off
oh
well
um
hopefully we can now do it
uh all right
great stuff okay we make the one changes
yep and i think we'll probably want to
do one more iteration of this
um
but uh
nice functionality it's taking a while
okay see you guys soon